[Musique]
en avril c'est le grand déménagement sur
ces 8
et pour cause de nombreuses émissions de
bricolage et de découvrons débarquer sur
la chaîne pour bricoler dans la bonne
humeur et être bien chez vous je vous
invite à participer à un ensemble
agricole à partir du samedi 3 avril
caroline ithurbide va présenter ensemble
on bricole un nouveau programme
totalement inédit dans laquelle
l'animatrice va se rendre chez des
particuliers pour leur donner un coup de
main échangée leur intérieur vous
aimeriez réaliser des travaux chez vous
pour améliorer votre intérieur
installer un îlot central poser du
carrelage rénové à me poser une paroi de
douche créer un potager
tous ces petits et grands travaux
n'auront plus aucun secret pour vous
voilà la promesse de cette émission des
missions qui ne sera pas la seule dans
ce genre puisque la chaîne a décidé de
lancé également m comme maison un
programme incarné par stéphane thébaut
le célèbre animateur de la maison france
5 pour l'émission s'est arrêtée il ya
quelques mois seulement et je sais que
vous serez avec nous fidèle au rendez
vous merci
il sera accompagné de tania bruna-rosso
tous deux avec leur expert on retrouvera
notamment karine martin gars et puis si
stéphanie et cécile siméone ils vont
présenter aux téléspectateurs 10 astuces
déco était à visiter des maisons à
l'architecturé incroyable un programme à
découvrir à partir du vendredi 16 avril
en prime time
alors le bricolage et la déco débarque
sur ces 8 j'y crois les bonnes questions
et on remarque quand même qu'il ya quand
même majoritairement j'ai envie de vous
dire non seulement c'est normal parce
qu'on est corpore tenue au delà du côté
corporate depuis le confinement vous
savez qu'il ya pour tous les magasins de
bricolage de rénovation d'un terrain
tout une augmentation de +6 et demi pour
cent parce que tout le monde a vu que ce
serait un coup trop sinon maintenant on
voyait que ça craignait un peu c'est
dommage d'être dans des intérieurs et de
faire du télétravail dans un espace
qu'on n'aime pas donc tout le monde
réaménagé sont donc c'est une niche qui
a été un peu laissé de côté prochaine on
a envie de retrouver ça on n'y croit pas
oui mac mini qui n'y croient pas et
harcelé messieurs caroline
on est clairement sur une déclinaison de
tous en cuisine version bricolage sauf
que le bricolage pour moi mais pas
suffisamment fédérateur le samedi matin
vous allez vous y mettre ce qui va sur
les émissions de bricolage c'est l'avant
il après l'effet waouh
là on est plus sûr des tutos c'est vrai
que lorsqu'on regarde et la grande
maison à vendre le tuto dure 3 minutes
sur la dette et des choses et puis
concernant caroline au chat dort
caroline mais on fêtait les spécialistes
de tout ce remue les mets
et du bricolage sait pas trop où me
positionner en revanche c'est l'axé mais
oui j'ai votre lettre de la wii d'accord
je pense que maxime tu n'as rien compris
au concept en cette soirée bien
tranquille
justement c'est du pl est la proximité
elle est accompagnée d'un professionnel
du bricolage sera en duplex avec des
jeux wii manetons mairie autour de la
table c'est à dire comme ça maxime on a
du bon roi des produits bricolage donc
voilà c'est jouer la proximité
l'émission avec stéphane thébaut pareil
ça va dans la conduite continuité de
l'avenir de ces huit conseillers qui
veut devenir le chef de file good on en
train de regarder corps et franchement
bravo parce qu'aujourd'hui ça change en
plus le samedi à 10h des émissions de
télé shopping on n'a pas eu le voir que
leur cas soit les toits nema j'ai été
bon mais trop cru pour ces huit quand
même bien sûr c'est une bonne recrue
mais au-delà de ça je suis d'accord avec
kevin c'est vrai que c'est un programme
feel good et la casquette et choisit du
samedi matin c'est vrai que c'est une
très bonne case parce que le samedi
matin c'est typiquement le programme
qu'on a envie de voir
et au delà d'haïti est c'est vrai que
moi mais ça le matin j'avais de quoi de
planter un clou ces programmes se sent
impliqué dedans parce que ça peut donner
des idées pour refaire notre appartement
notre maison voilà avoir des
modifications non vraiment je vois là
j'adore ça va marcher tu le sens pour
compléter c'est vrai que toutes les
chaînes ont décidé justement de revenir
sur ce côté là parce qu on le sait on va
être confiné à priori qu'on va être chez
vous de quoi avoir envie de la voir un
super intérieur et à une ciste
d'ailleurs qui va lancer la deuxième
saison de bien chez soi avec stéphane
plaza et moi je trouve que l'idh étude
de m caroline ithurbide c'est vers ce
que c'est tellement une quiche qu'on va
tous se retrouver en face à ces vendeurs
là je
je veux garder parce que ni n'aime pas
non plus c'est pas que j'aime pas c'est
que je sais bien pour caroline parce que
ça va la mettre en avant en plus de ce
qu'elle fait parce que moi j'aime bien
ce qu'elle fait et j'y crois moyen dans
le sens où
à depuis des comptes sur m6 je pense que
les gens se sont lassés un petit peu de
clics et bricolage de tout ce qui est
décoration d'intérieur ex-agent de
marouflage est donc là ça n'a rien à
voir avec le marouflage et c'est plus du
deck au delà du bricolage pardon mais
moi personnellement je regarderai pas
l'une concernant thébaux est ce que
c'était celui-ci ne céderons il nous
rappelle d'ailleurs l'arrivée de william
leymergie sur la chaîne ça fait partie
de grosses de grosses personnalités de
france télévisions puisqu'il faisait la
maison france 1 il sait pas trop détaché
du titre justement pour tout voir un
petit peu fidéliser et ramener ces c'est
son public c'était les spectateurs et ça
je pense que c'est un très très grand
coup de pied 8